Mark Heidelberger, Producer: I just need three
things from you: I need a script, I need a
budget and I need you to get the hell out
of my way.
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT
I’m not a huge fan of academics.
I’m not a huge fan of people who just teach
and haven’t done in 20 years.
I like to learn from the people who are doing
it now.
ON TUESDAY, NOVEMBER 13TH, 2018
You can’t just give me a script “How much
does it cost?”
“Well is Matt Damon in your movie?
Great!
Your budget just went up by 10 million dollars.”
I can make an argument to do this movie by
one million bucks or 10 million bucks.
So really it’s like “So how much can you
raise?
Or how much do you have?”
And then if they really don’t have a good
idea of who they see in it, how wide do you
see it being distributed but I have to get
an idea of what range and how big they are
seeing this in their head.
WE INVITE YOU TO JOIN US AND PRODUCER MARK
HEIDELBERGER
If you just want to go out and make a piece
of art for yourself and you have the money
to blow, go ahead.
But that doesn’t mean you are going to be
part of the entertainment industry.
It doesn’t mean you are going to be part
of the film…business.
It is a business as well as a commodity as
well as art.
That’s where people get hung up - it’s
art, right.
But it’s also a commodity.
FOR A ONE NIGHT ONLY EVENT
I read an article the other day (maybe it
was like a month ago) it was like a cartoon.
My head was like VROOOOM!
I was so annoyed with this article.
It just started with “Okay, now you’ve
finished your film.
Now it’s time to start thinking about distribution.”
I’m like “No!
No!
It’s not time to start, you should have
been thinking about distribution ages ago.
From the script stage you should have been
thinking about distribution.”
And I’ve told people, the smart way to do
it (and they always have a script that they
just really want to do) and I’m like “Well
have you considered your audience?
Have you considered whether there is an audience
for it?
Have you considered how you are going to get
that audience?
Have you considered how big that audience
is and whether it justifies the budget you
want to spend?
Have you looked at the market, what other
films are out there in the market?
How oversaturated that is.
I can’t tell you how many times I hear people
say “I’m going to do horror because it’s
so cheap,” so you can make a bunch of money
off of it.
You’re only considering one thing, you’re
only considering budget.
EVENT INFO BELOW
When I read the script I’m thinking about
story.
I’m thinking about the arc of the characters,
I’m thinking about conflict and I’m thinking
about why are we telling this story but I’m
also thinking about “Okay, who would we
get to play these roles on this budget level?
What are some decent names?
Who am I picturing in this?
I’m presuming in this situation that the
movie is real, that it’s not just a script.
That I’m not just reading it for fun like
we’re making this picture.
This picture is funded, Mark.
Read the script.
So I’m reading it and I’m like “Okay,
how are we going to pull off this…we need
this grandiose house?”
STRAIGHT TALK ABOUT FEATURE FILM DEVELOPMENT
AND PRODUCTION - A NIGHT WITH MARK HEIDELBERGER
It’s a lot easier to develop a story in
synopsis form or treatment form then it is
to keep rewriting the script when there is
fundamental problems with it.
You don’t start building the building “Ahhh?
It’s slanted…alright let’s start taking
out some bricks and try to get it straight.”
You work all of that in the design phase,
the blueprint phase.
So that’s what I try to get them to.
And the 12 questions to me is Okay, that’s
that beginning, that organic seed that we
need to plant to make a healthy tree grow.
What’s your theme?
What’s your thematic question?
Why are you telling this?
The thematic question is what you pose to
the audience.
It could be a moral question or something
else.
But some question you want them to think about
like “Is family really just people you’re
related to?
Or is it something more?”
It can be your thematic question.
It’s not overtly stated in the question
but it’s in the film’s subconscious, it’s
what your film is kind of really about.
And then your theme is how you answer that
question by the end.
That’s how you answer your thematic question.
So what are those things?
I have a great story I think I can tell within
that and consulting with distributors and
sales agents who know the market place and
if you’re afraid to get the sales agents
and distributors involved early and find out
what the market looks like and what buyers
are looking for.
And what budget ranges but if you don’t
want to do that and you make a picture that
makes no money, really you don’t have anyone
to blame but yourself.
The end use, the marketing, distribution,
publicity, festivals (all of that), you should
be looking at that from the beginning, from
inception of your story.
Just like you trust a DP to shoot your picture
because he knows more about lighting and camera
than you do.
Or an editor because he knows a lot more about
cutting than you do.
Distributors and sales agents know more about
selling in the market than you do.
And so if you want a better chance at getting
some sort of return, involve people that know
more about what they do than you do about
what they do.
I say this all the time when I hire people.
I say “Look, you know more about what you
do than I know about what you do.
So I’m going to tell you the results I want,
when I want it by, I’m going to tell you
and I’m going to tell you what resources
I’m going to give you to get me that result.
If you say “I can do it.”
I’ll say “Great, go do it.”
And I’m here to support you or “Hey, I
need you to do this or that as long as it’s
in these parameters, done!
If there’s a problem, we’ll fix it and
we’ll make sure it doesn’t happen again.”
Trust but verify.
But I don’t stand over their shoulders.
I hired you because this is what you do and
you’re better at it than I am, so go do
it.
And the crew loves that!
Straight Talk About Feature Film Development
And Production.
A Night With Mark Heidelberger on November
13th, 2018 in North Hollywood, CA.